Denny Hamlin two-time Daytona 500 winner
and decent basketball player got the
basketball court here in the man cave
and then Denny's actually got a full
court in his house their indoor
basketball court who's the best
basketball player ever played at your
house Denny well actually here let me
take these off I would say ah malik monk
from charlotte actually have um first
sport management who represents me
actually runs has a scalp and an agent
that runs mba guys through my house so
we've had a quite a few guys we've had a
lot of college kids who get ready for
the combine yeah will come over to my
house and do some workouts but jordan
has not been over no jordan's you know
not in charlotte that much he spends a
lot of time at the fur ideon yeah
playing playing ball yeah so i would say
you know he hasn't but yeah we uh i see
a lot of college kids go through there
that are getting ready for the NBA i I
don't know when this story happened but
you text Michael and Michael said if you
win then I'll publicly announce that
you're better than me at driving is that
the story like yeah it does Michael
really think he could drive a NASCAR um
I don't know I mean I think he went
through that phase with the motorcycles
right he had the bike team for a long
time and you know I didn't realize you
know his passion for racing itself until
you know later on down the line in our
friendship and he was like you know yeah
my dad used to take me to NASCAR races
at Darlington when I was a kid in South
Carolina so yeah it was a it just struck
up a friendship and you know every now
and then he and he you know I go down to
Florida and play some golf with him
during the week and and have a good time
does he talk trash he does but I'll be
honest with the he's he's pretty much
business on the golf course you know
he's got a lot of action going between a
lot of bets yeah but I'll tell you what
there's one thing
his group I found out you cannot play
slow period and when we when I say slow
I had my group of friends fly down with
me to go play and there was a I joined
his group which now made us a seven
seven and and they were a threesome
behind us and we played in three hours
and five minutes for our seven some and
we literally waited on them for the
three twenty minutes the threesome into
play and you always got to play from the
back all the way from the tip to it's
just a normal normal deal but I'm
telling you you drive to your ball and
you hit like if there's someone fifteen
yards in front of you they get to their
ball yet pay for it just heads up it's
coming over your head so there's a lot
of trust in those guys how much money um
I mean a few thousand will get exchanged
hands but nothing nothing that'll make
you nothing that'll make those guys
nervous uncomfortable I would say yeah
but you it's got to be cash - yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's in the bag yeah you
better you better be coming prepared
with a with a little bag in your in your
bag but you so how did you start how did
you become part of his brand so I met
him at a basketball game in 2009 and
just literally at Charlotte and he
stopped me as I'm walking by he's like
hey you know hey I'm Michael nice to
meet you and I'm like yeah of course
right and so did he actually say honey
Michael he didn't and so and so we
exchanged phone numbers at that you know
as I'm you know because we're hey you
know can't stop the traffic so we
exchanged phone numbers and lexing no
we're texting the second half of this
basketball do you text him first or do
you would Lisa's like a date no we're
going down honestly but let's just say
he texts me first it sounds better than
yeah yeah and we just started talking
and you know a little bit about racing
and whatnot and so starting from that
point on he started texting me you know
yeah almost every other week or so just
saying hey good luck
this weekend and then he'll text me
after the race and say a good job or you
know what the hell did you do why'd you
do that and this past weekend when I
finished second you know on the last lap
it was a you know expletive he's like
Damon you know there's like they're so
close that he you know you should have
moved them and I'm like yeah I know I
should have I should have knocked him
out of the way he's like he would have
done it to you you get him first you
know and not so he's pretty passionate
about it second place sucks as you said
it's it sucks because we had the best
car in it I don't know it's just too
nice but also I don't know I just I need
to do it over again I'll learn from that
mistake but what would you do
differently
I shouldn't have backed off down the
back straightaway I was beside them in
the power position if you're gonna you
know be running into each other in the
final corner you want to be on the
bottom because you can ultimately just
knock the guy up the racetrack and for
me I was thinking well what's gonna
happen is I'm gonna go in the corner
he's gonna back off and they just ran
right into me in the next in the last
corner I should have kept the bottom so
I could move him up like he moved me up
so it was just two veteran guys that
have been doing this for a long time
that we're trying to outthink each other
and he got the best of me last but how
much physics goes into this I I don't
know yeah like aerodynamics they I don't
know if people talk about that that much
it's such a huge factor now I mean we're
driving our racing line right now to
avoid other cars in the corners but I
mean really when it comes down to short
tracks it's a different type of racing
now and I think Kevin Harvick said it
last week where you know guys run into
each other with no with reckless abandon
and more than more so now than they ever
have so I think it's just a new era of
drivers that are that are younger that
you know just to have the you know kind
of I don't care attitude and but you're
also more protected than you've ever
been
I don't know we're sure they yeah
there's a false sense of security with a
safety standpoint yeah yeah no doubt
about it but I think that it drivers now
nowadays have just the mentality it's
it's win or nothing and
and do whatever it takes and if you piss
someone off then it's oh well you'll
deal with that later where I think the
younger the older guys have the more
let's you know have respect and let's do
this the right way so it's kind of a
clash of personalities right now but
isn't this what NASCAR used to be that
it was all or nothing with you know
Richard Petty and Dale Earnhardt senior
and then did why did we back off with
that aggressive nature it became more
corporate there are the bigger sponsors
you got you know I know me personally
with FedEx on my chest I'm representing
many many many employees in a big
company that that you know you you got
to watch what you say you got to kind of
watch what you do but also are you you
need to stay in the race longer for
their logo to be seen for a longer
period of time I'm guessing is that
factor in with a little a little bit but
not really I mean really the work that
they do to activate is done well before
the car hits the racetrack its
hospitality things like that but at the
racetrack that they're entertaining
guests we're doing pictures by the race
car right before the race itself so
their work is done the competition side
is just really a side aspect to it
Denny is running a brand-new paint job
at Watkins Glen for a safe kids it's a
charity that helps raise awareness of
distracted walking and driving and
what's the new paint scheme gonna be
yeah it's it's it's pretty cool and you
mentioned the safe kids you know back a
handful of years ago probably five or
six years ago FedEx announced that they
were gonna donate 200 million to 200
communities by 2020 and they hit that
goal six months early and now this is
about you know I think a lot of people
think that big companies they should you
know they write big checks and that's
kind of what they do to give back to the
community well this you know now they've
had of a new initiative to let's affect
50 million people by our 50th
anniversary in 2023 so well this is
about affecting people not just writing
a big check and they do a lot of both
that a lot of emergencies and disasters
that they
one of the first responders to so I'm
proud to you know represent FedEx it's
been you know a sponsor mine now for 14
years last year on Dale Junior's podcast
you said that there's a reason why you
feel unpopular you don't take good
pictures you always look like you're
angry I got a bad resting be face is
that is that true that you yeah just
don't look friendly or nice or yeah like
but what look are you going for here um
I just think you know my resting
[ __ ] is really bad that's all I can
think of you know it's just I look at
pictures that get posted on me or
somebody you know I'm just like but oh
so that's the face but I'm thinking I'm
thinking well what are you thinking
about if you're getting my car like why
isn't it going faster all kinds of
things
it's just what can you do fake you know
I think that I've had altercations with
popular drivers during the course of my
career so ultimately you know fans you
know they don't forget and so I think
just some some altercations I had
earlier in my career has affected my
popular in this but I I don't I don't I
hate to say I don't care but it's like I
really care about performing on the
racetrack and that's really my main
focus you can't change it now Danny no
you can't and that's the thing is that
I'm you know what you're 14 in my career
this is you know I'm not out to get you
know the most popular the most clicks on
my Instagram or anything like that at
this point I'm just trying to do the
best I can to represent my sponsor well
that way I keep them and that way I keep
a ride you can you do a fake smile
that's a fake smile or is that a real
smile that's oh why don't you think of a
funny movie whenever you're getting your
picture too I don't know because they're
hidden these cameras are hidden you
don't know where they're coming from
oh okay so these are when you're in
action yeah this isn't like my pose okay
pictures I look normal and pose picture
normal it's the you know the the
pictures you don't expect you're sitting
there and you're trying to explain your
crew chief next to no you get a picture
taken but why is it Jeff Gordon always
looked good
I think he's aware of he must have
someone tapping on his shoulder saying
hey by the way although when he went
with the moustache that was a wrong move
for for Jeff with the Mustang he was
trying to mature himself well beyond his
years but I think he was trying because
seen Dale senior had the mustache and I
think he might have said hey I'm gonna
I'm gonna look tough like Dale's he
couldn't he couldn't grow that it looked
like hedges yeah with with Dale senior
it was like he was born with it
do you find it interesting like I do
with Dale you know Dale jr. that this
whole personality has come out where he
didn't really show a lot of print he was
the most popular driver without really
showing his personality so I knew Dale
when he was closed off and he was quiet
and you know back back in his smoking
days yeah it's just now coming out you
know you had a smoking problem right and
so I remember him and honestly what
changed him was his wife Amy in my
opinion I think that I remember sitting
down with him I can't remember I was at
his house or whatever and he was just
like you know you know this girl man
she's you know and I was around him when
he was dating other people and he was
like man this girl she's just she knocks
my socks off man she's just she's great
I can hear him saying she's just great
in every way and I just think that that
that she had such a positive influence
on him coming out of his shell and I
remember when she came into his life he
started instead of being in the bus for
three days during the race weekend he
was going to dinners that you know in
the local area and trying to just get
out a little bit more and not caring
about you know I think I don't know and
I can't I might be speaking wrong here
but I think you know he he was true he
was doing his best on the racetrack
right and he was carrying the earnhardt
name well but he's always getting
compared to his dad and that's how that
is such a such a tough thing to do and I
can see where you would kind of not live
shame but like just gosh you know how am
I ever gonna live up to that and I think
that he started being comfortable in his
own skin to be his own man and and
everyone appreciated the man that he was
and he was popular regardless of his dad
he still had people that he that he
resonated with so I think he's just a
great person in general and I commend
him for making really the life changes
that he made you know once he met Amy
which Dale senior around did you ever
meet him I didn't I didn't get to meet
Dale you know obviously with him passing
in 2001 I came into the sport in 2004 so
I didn't get an opportunity to meet him
so I it's one of the kind of the regrets
that you have is you know I'm very happy
to be in NASCAR and the era that I'm in
was safety taking us such a big leap
it's unfortunate we had to lose all the
drivers that we did for it to get there
but I'm blessed to be in this era how
when do you start to notice when you're
not at your peak like at what what age
what's the first thing to go you know I
think that sometimes you've it's just
your reactions are a little slower and
and you just and you just start to see
it that it takes a little bit more time
to react to certain things you got to
work work harder to be better and
there's some of the young guys that come
in it they've just got the wrong speed
but they don't it's not refined in and
we've seen in NASCAR over the last
couple years that the young guys I mean
they are fast but they're not they're
still not winning races like the old
guys are they're still not as dominant
as the old guys are still not contending
for championships like the old guys
because it is still a thinking man sport
it is a game of chess out there where
it's not all about raw speed there's
strategy that goes into it making sure
you you're saving your car for the end
of the race things like that so it is
still a veteran sport right now what do
you like in traffic not just regular
traffic I'm actually pretty normal so
people ask that all the time you know do
you have problem driving the speed limit
on the railroad and I always say no
because that is a
few minutes that I have by myself
so I like to take as much time as I can
to get to point B while I'm in my car I
mean I just don't you mind driving or be
a passenger now if it's over one hour
I'm not driving I need someone over
there which is interesting because I
raced for three and a half hours on
Sunday yeah but I just yeah I don't like
driving for a long extended period of
time
yeah I prefer to ride if it's long
distance
Seaton's got a Prius in the parking lot
you're a Toyota guy you know yep you
could do you think you could get to New
York and you think you could you know
burn the tires a little bit the Prius
yeah mmm probably no I mean tough to
burn the tires you got any oil something
we could do do you drive a sensible car
that gets good gas mileage actually I
just got my new to it a super in tech
VIN number 11 I'm pretty excited about
that yeah yeah Alexis LFA's Nurburgring
Edition number 300 that's now you know
if the values really going up on those
so what's your favorite car of all time
favorite car of all time I have the the
entourage car 67 Lincoln Continental not
v1 from the show no but it's jut it is
identical yeah saw it in a the W in
Scottsdale salt in valet they're told
the valet guy says find out who owns
that car and tell him to leave the keys
here as long as he's reasonable on his
price so the guy car was like hey guy
said that I should leave my car here um
you're wanting to buy it
I was like yeah how much will it take
he's like I don't know man like 70 maybe
I'm like how about like 60 and you leave
the keys like okay okay I'll do it so so
yeah got a little work done to it since
then and got it all straight so I
actually you know I took I fly my plane
kind of where well I don't fly
but I take it to all the races so our
next race was Phoenix and so I or I'm
sorry our next race was in Vegas so I
just told I took all my people that
usually fly me like yeah you go there
I'll meet you I'll meet you drove I
drove the car out there says awesome
that's great hey it's great to see ya
happy for you you know great success
there and stop finishing second all
right
tell me about it because you're gonna
hear from Jordan yeah Denny running that
brand new paint scheme at Watkins Glen
for safe kids a wonderful charity that
helps raise awareness of distracted
walking and driving
Denny Hamlin great to see him for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]